continue des progrès significatifs
réalisés par l'Ukraine dans dans la mise
en la de la mise en œuvre des SEP
recommandations de la Commission
européenne en seulement 16 mois reconnu
par le paquet d'élargissement de l'Union
Européen du 8 novembre 2023 nous
attendons une décision
politique du Conseil européen d'entamer
des négociations d'adhésion avec
l'Ukraine lors de sa réunion le 14 et 15
décembre
nous comprenons
clairement que nous ne sommes pas que au
début du chemin vers l'adhésion à part
un tiers à l'Union Européen et que nous
sommes déterminés à poursuivre les
transformations aujourd'hui l'Ukraine
l'Europe ont absolument besoin l'une de
l'autre il s'agit des rétablissement de
la justice historique et un accord
gagnant gagnant